more awesome interviews from radio row
and we have the McCourty twins you'll
drop some pizza off you guys have like
probably the best promotion we hear a
lot of promotions this week this is the
coolest one tell us what y'all are doing
yeah like you said we bought three pizza
but number one you brought us food
exactly thank you pizzas giving out more
free it's been cool I think even for us
to do it obviously we're twins and Pizza
Hut doing something with twins and talk
about how big moms are and I think we
have twins moms are even bigger like
they're their true MVPs Kevin Durant
said but this year Sunday for the Super
Bowl after kickoff if you're a mom and
you're having twins you have the
opportunity to wear free pizza for two
years you have a chance to go to Super
Bowl 55 next year and you have a chance
to get twenty-two thousand dollars for
your twin scholarship fund and it's easy
all you have to do you go on Twitter I
have to kick off like he said post a
picture of the twins the date and the
time they were born all you have to do
on Twitter at Pizza Hut
hashtag pH 20 win hashtag promotion and
that enters you and you have a chance to
win all of that cool stuff free pizza
for two years I have kids you are so
much excited so how great was this last
year we actually have a third co-host
who's my brother who's not here with us
so I know how great that is to work with
your brother you know all the like
little details you give to a [ __ ] all
the time how great is that for you guys
to finally be back together it was so
cool and to spend nine years apart Mon
nine and aleihi I want you at Rutgers I
didn't came and and our own rights both
of us became captains of the team's are
on both of us had a good amount of
individual success obviously he had a
ton more team successes I never went to
the playoffs but being able to come
together and see the growth that we both
had for me to sit in that room and see
the way the organization viewed him and
he's always just been my brother to me
the way we call each other out like
anybody that's in the meeting room with
us they see how me and everyone wants
each other like if he gets beat I'll
call him out like you should've did this
that in a third I think that enables us
to both raise our games to higher levels
has it always been like that even going
back to high school in Jersey when you
guys played together on top of each
other like that we play
basketball in high school it'd be a
timeout and our coach would be on a knee
he's trying to get the timeout but we
would be arguing over laughs what
happened last day like you're not
playing good enough defense on man up
and then our coach Mike both of you shut
up
we get like 10 seconds for him to talk
after we took up the whole minute
timeout so who's the better basketball
player I was he's gonna of course a
first he said he got he got spotlighted
more we have to find the highlights
online somewhere right you guys still
played you still compete like in
everything you do though it never really
goes away right yeah I think our
competitions like if we ever had a
chance to be on the same team and go
against somebody else that was always
our ideal situation so that's why these
last two years but I think within being
on the same team our competition comes
from just trying to make each other
better that's what we're always trying
to trying to pull out of one another now
you guys are rarity because not only are
you one of 13 sets of twins I think that
it played in the NFL but I don't think
Bill Belichick likes a lot of people and
he likes and he likes both of you what I
mean is because they went to Rutgers
yeah but do you know how we do stuff
like this going to his office I what
what is Bill really like because you
know we've started to see a peek behind
the current with the Nick Saban
documentary and and you know now he's
doing the NFL 100 stuff but what is he
like as a player I think the one thing
you know was like what you're watching I
was talking that's what he loves talking
history football American history like
he loves that stuff so I think when you
see that like you see him at the
happiest place for him and I think for
us as players that's what happens like
he loves you know obviously he gets on
us he's hard on us but he loves just
teaching the game of football
brilliant and he's prepared us and
especially me 10 years there I can
remember small moments that we're
playing the Jets my rookie year and it's
like mid-december and he's a you know on
this sideline the wind blows this way so
be ready if you get a fade route over
here the ball is not gonna travel far
it's gonna kind of get there and just
drop so if you run and turn your head
right away I turn my head get an
interception that and I remember I
walked away and I was I
he just predicted what was gonna happen
in the game and I think like that's what
he loves to do so I think I was most
surprised at just how chill and call me
is I went into New England thinking it
was gonna be militant like everybody was
on top you like I had just left
Cleveland I'm going all-in 16 and we had
to be at like every meeting five minutes
early but everybody had to be wearing
Cleveland Browns gear to every meet and
I get to New England and it's like 7:58
our first means that we gotta go he was
just saying you're not late till is they
don't want like but everybody just
strolls around you're wearing you come
straight in from outside got your hood
on and so it's just it's all about just
football and it doesn't matter outside
sometimes former teammates kind of
cracker guys like him completely right
now me I mean maybe you know if he can
crash the interview and steal your pizza
he can play for the Patriots right
that's true nobody wanna know if you're
getting ready if you're getting ready to
have twins
we got pepperoni so we got a chance for
you to win some free pizza for two years
tickets to the Super Bowl and some
scholarship but you gotta be given birth
to twins so go to Twitter have twins
first step 1/2 they just got to be born
they got to be born after kickoff Sunday
so it's like two lays it the first
person well we're not gonna give it to
you because you see you know people are
what they're doing so you're not gonna
treat the dogs right like the way you
said that like he has a dog
the dog's name is Winston people who are
only learning this Martellus Bennett and
she's completely hijacked you got
everyone it's great it's hot - yeah
we're bleacher report he hates that
phrase don't get him going
no it's ironic we got tired of people
telling us stick to football whatever
right now we're talking about pizza no
Jack don't say Michael I do ask you guys
because the hot topic right now Marcel
still freeway in what's Tom Brady gonna
do hold on but this thing is official I
feel like I'm like I'm what's the movie
with the Top Gun yes with the
good-looking white dude once a Britney
song cool yeah Tom Cruise yeah I got you
alright so yes Tom alright so here's the
thing right tom is a legacy guy there's
not a lot of legacy guys left in the NFL
so it's hard when you build your legacy
one franchise for 39 years however long
Tom's been there right he's been there
forever forever since you know since the
beginning of time tom has he's even
battle tom and he's won that right so
this guy's amazing he's really good he's
really great but I think it's
interesting that he goes into a new
jungle and figure it out because I think
the interesting thing that Tom wants to
know and the world wants to know is it
bill or is it Tom is it the system or is
it the guy and I think this gives him a
chance to just do well somewhere else to
show that he can play without this
system I'm not a system guy I'm I can't
say mother mother [ __ ] Tom Brady I'm
handsome I'm rich I stretch all the time
I'm piebald
I got T b12 and I sell my own
means my wife is a supermodel and my
kids speak four languages before eight
no bad days when you're Tom Brady
guacamole ice cream well avvocato ice
cream same thing same thing so I think
that Tom I think it's I think it's one
of those things that easily look where
when he's in another jersey but everyone
at some point has to wear another jersey
so Joe Montana was the chief right so
anything's possible
yeah he was but no one remembers that
that's right that's only thing I do I
was a Niners fan uh you don't want to be
a boxer witness to when your time's up
you know saying you want to steal why
you could perform at a high level so I
think a good place for Tom I think he
has I don't know I don't really watch
football I just watch these guys cuz I'm
right there they were so great in the
beginners season defense was doing so
well they said he fence Dan should just
change what did change I don't know I
just saw it's like man I love these guys
and I'm like 17 interceptions they did
saying you could turn on a TV while
seeing I'm high five but the defense is
high-fiving on television all the time
yeah you guys are great I mean no one's
even so we play better teams with better
quarterbacks yeah and after Halloween
the boogeyman had to put the costumes
away so they disappear right how hard is
it when you do have to see a Patrick
mom's out there it's tough thanks Marty
appreciate you man my home's my homes is
so good man's ability to run his ability
to make every throw whether he's inside
the pocket outside the packet back leg
whatever it is and then to be honest
what I was so impressed by especially
last year was just how poised he was no
matter what it was like early Rotundo an
AFC championship game we totally shut
him out in the first half and he didn't
bat an eye he came out in the second all
right I'm just gonna put points up a ton
of points to another way and in two year
old team the Titans down 24 9 yeah and
just a sad one before halftime and then
comes out the second half and just look
like he was converted every single third
down so he's very tough I'm looking
forward to see what San Francisco's from
like six because there's D lineman at
all rotate what kind of pressures are
able to get on himself it'll be a fun
game to watch man I can't wait now Devin
you've been there I mean forever since
I've been in your career do you have to
convince your brother a little bit
like hey you want to be over here with
New England or was it more like telling
the coaches like hey me my brother again
we've been good together for a long time
actually shot bill the text message
you know so he hits me he goes the
Browns are gonna release him saw my man
is probably the last shot Tex bill hey
Bill
Jay max getting released Touma Cory's
are better than one doesn't text me back
so I was like I guess the whole family
thing is not gonna work here calls him
at like 45 minutes later and it's like
we actually just trade a forum he's
gonna be on the team
oh so I mean he really needs to thank me
for a lot that's happened to him I mean
if you're boring now then give me a game
or Center the contract what percentage I
had to take a pay cut to stay I can't
really think you might owe some money
well he didn't give me any but any of
his Super Bowl money
I didn't I was paying for tickets how is
it to go for the own 16 Browns to the
New England Patriots but for all of us
as we were kids the Patriots have not
been bad 20 years of greatness and you
go from the worst team in NFL history to
the New England Patriots the greatest
team in history I mean were you just
like Scrooge McDuck swimming around and
your money was happy I just saw Mary Kay
who's a beat reporter for the Browns in
the hall why she was a how are you doing
it's like a lot better since I but I
think it was surreal you know you never
could imagine from that point when that
season ended I hey next year towards the
beginning of February I'll be standing
in confetti in Atlanta winning the
Superbowl and I remember when we won the
game I went up to Danny Shelton whose
Locker was right next to mine for the
year I was in Cleveland and we just
looked at each other because you know
how rough it was there was games
Cleveland you go out there week after
week you're losing the only thing that
consoles you go home we order you some
pizza I eat with the kids I have and you
have a good time but it was it was it
was unreal I remember sitting with dev
we went on NFL Network after the game my
mom mom came on there are two of our
kids were with us on there and just
soaking in all of those moments of for
Super Bowls prior to that being down
here during this time throughout the
week with my family supporting and last
year being able to actually
live it and be a part of it playing an
entire game every snap I mean it was it
was unbelievable that's awesome well we
can't thank you guys enough and a huge
thanks to Pizza Hut if you guys want to
give the shout out one more time for
what yeah game you have a shot to win
$22,000 in scholarship money you have a
chance to win three Pizza free pizzas we
talked about that that's the big thing
to me and a chance I mean the smallest
thing on here is you'll get to go to
Super Bowl 55 I guess I'd be great if
the Patriots are there I say you guys
you gonna be there you think next year
Oh
the Patriots pick up a team option in
Super Bowl I will be there I'll be there
in a Super Bowl you'll be there well if
you if you don't you got to make sure
you enter this contest so you could take
is all you got to do is post a picture
on Twitter at Pizza Hut
hashtag pH 22 win hashtag promotion I
don't know if I could get pregnant by
Sunday one way to find out is to try the
wipes out here alright boys thanks for
stopping by and if you see Marty time
thanks for thank him for